get to the love part let's go to the
love yeah we have
we have george here he's getting married
it's a really weird time to get married
um
so i want to know coming from the king
himself what you think
are what advice can you give to a newly
married man
five five five tips on love hot tapes
what did you think should you ask me the
king
i thought you were asking him no i'm
asking you what tips can you give
our bachelor soon to be groom
on love and life and the pandy okay
always get the hot towel afterwards so i
won
always get the hot towel afterwards how
do you keep the towel hot
good well you go to the you get whatever
a dish rag or something
a dish or whatever use or not clean
whatever
yeah you put a little lukewarm water on
it yes
and while you know your beautiful
princess and laying on the bed
tatiana tatiana either
handed to her i've thrown it before
hang on different ways yeah like here
clean yourself up lady or whatever you
might want to say
yeah right i wouldn't say it that way or
or go
would you damn a british accent say
would you like a hot towel would you
like a hot towel
there we go right right that feels right
because you have [ __ ] in your eyes
yeah yeah maybe do with that they say
come in yeah and
you have a sperm in your eyes i think
it's perfect
yeah you have sperm in your heart let's
keep try ski
you have skeet in your eyes oh i think
it is it's alright
you're done can you leave oh no i have
to sleep
something like that because that's
number one that's number one hang on one
second i have more
regarding number two the hot towel
follow-up
um okay never mind keep all the receipts
keep all the restaurant receipts
for tax purposes no so that you know
because you're paying for all the meals
right oh i started doing i started
telling her how much you cost me
everywhere
every month that's what but you do it
suddenly it's healthy you get
this is how much you cost me just know
how much you're worth and then when she
cheats that she ever cheats on you if
she ever cheats on you
then you just take half of each receipt
and
bill her okay
i mean i just feel really dejected
because i've never in the seven years
we've been together i have never seen a
single hot dish rag thrown at her or
give it to me
not even like a t-shirt thrown at me
yeah nothing
but baby be honest with you he just like
rolls over and then farts no no baby
be honest with me do i get a lot of [ __ ]
that comes out
skeet just use the word skeet please
well to be fair
nothing needs to really be wiped down
after because you
you do produce like micro millimeter
that's what i'm talking about
micro dosing it's good yeah it's like a
little you know so yeah i guess in that
sense no one really needs
a hot towel yeah they need like one
cl like a quarter of a kleenex or a
toilet q-tip a q-tip okay number three
number three all right number three
um learn to sleep
with your eyes open ooh that's a very
ninja training so that you know when you
guys because some movie nights
you know you would probably suggest
let's watch godfather or whatever
and then she's like let's watch the new
ryan reynolds or ryan gosling singing in
the rain
musical right you can what
have the watch it but you could be
asleep
i would just draw eyes on top of my lids
do that too okay all right okay but hang
on one second before you get on to
number four and five bobby
um do you george are you somebody that
likes to
um um lay down together snuggle and
watch a movie are you that type
oh yeah are most oh yeah did i just pick
a faulty one because i feel like i
always thought most people were like
that to like
watch and cuddle together but he
he yeah we did it last night yeah but
you were like this how did it go not
feeling it
i know i feel you could just feel like
he you described it describe what you
felt describe what you felt
i call it atmospherics
he will say okay let's do that but he
will create such an unpleasant
atmosphere
you're like you're like the aliens rival
arrival they can like correct that's
what you have this
she kept saying you're creating
atmosphere you're doing atmospherics
because
he will he'll be like yeah let's watch a
movie then he'll he'll plaster on like a
fake smile
and then he'll do this like get in here
yeah i know what you're talking about
i've seen him do it to you yeah yeah
and then the whole time you can just him
breathing like
and and so he he wants to
he really wants to um give in to what
you want but then punish you
at the same time so that's the number
four that triggered necessary
atmosphere that triggered me so much
because usually we're good at cuddling
yeah when we're at home but over
over the new years we were out uh
camping and we were in the back of my
truck
trying to watch toy story and instead of
watching it normally like sitting it in
between you and you just like have
pillows behind you
on an ipad she was like no i'm going to
watch it over here and you have to watch
it behind me and i was just stuck
staring at the back of her head good
woman good woman and what were you
thinking the whole time
i was like there's no way to make this
comfortable she's not thinking about me
at all this is new years
and then so then i just pretended to
sleep like to take a nap
and then i was just like she was like
went to the fireplace and was chatting
with my cousin's wife and i was just
like
it's new years get up and forget about
it because it's not worth it for just
toy story
and i was so mad the whole like
interesting it took me but did you
create
atmospherics george did you i had great
atmospherics you know and then she
ruined them by turning over and
were you breathing fire to the back of
her neck like he does to me
no i was trying not to i just roll i was
like i'm tired i'm wrong i rolled over
and then just
don't ruin new year's and it took me
like three weeks to tell her like how
mad i was after that
ah you need a process so you you're
somebody that holds it in
he's fairly he's kind of similar i guess
i hold it in
yeah it's not good to hold it in yeah oh
it was a lot better than ruining new
years
really oh i was no i waited until i
dissipated if i had
if i'd done it then and told her how bad
i was she would have been like
you're just supposed to watch it with me
but i feel like it sounds ridiculous
three weeks after when you're trying to
explain your rage and you're like you
know three weeks ago when we were
watching toy story
if you look at my i'm never watching toy
story again
that franchise is ruined for me but the
reason why i don't say it is because
i just let it pass because i don't know
i don't want to react
in the moment because whatever i'm
feeling in the moment isn't
necessarily real right i have to kind of
step away from the incident and go and
just kind of go
it's not that big of a deal but if i
react in the moment
right then it will cause a fight
right something that's that that i could
have avoided
right so i mean a lot of it has to do
with that but you holding it in does it
become a fight later on then
no it never does you know it just
becomes
usually it becomes an incident where i'm
like yeah it wasn't that big of a deal
and it's never that big of a deal it
never really is but i think that
sometimes like like what's the biggest
deal that you've ever
the mochi we could talk about the mochi
sometimes it is
yeah that the mochi was a big deal was
it
yeah he he wanted to break up with me
over mochi
i didn't want to break up with you
during well that's what you said
no no no you straight up said i
contemplated leaving no no i bring
but there is a for that one incident
yeah
i went that's crazy
i got yelled at and that was crazy so i
then i go
i go into a thing it's like you know
is it worth it i had bought mochi to
give away to friends
thank you right you got some nope okay
yes you did i did i just he's what he
was asking but it's like oh you didn't
george i was trying i was trying to help
you out
sorry yeah well but yeah
gilbert everyone got to accept you
anyways continue no
um so you know um
obviously people know kalila's
best friend that she grew up with
jessica who
you know who jessica is man oh yeah yeah
the girl
tatiana yeah yeah you know when you die
and they look at your heart there's
going to be a black spot
on the tip of your heart that's just
korean characters yeah
okay
all right so um jessica's a brother's
wife
is an an extremely good baker and she's
created she created a baking company
amazing and she makes
mochi products asian desserts rice
blossoms
cakes and um i'm telling you there
because we get
[ __ ] from japan it's up there it's
legitimately ask anyone that we've given
the right amazing
enjoy ask anyone but george who's had it
it's [ __ ] amazing
right everyone about yourself so one
morning i
i wake up and uh i go hmm i hungo
right i open a refrigerator yep and i
see
five boxes of that mochi
nice so i'm like hmm i'm gonna eat one
now because there's five boxes in there
and i put pulled one out
and it was there was a couple of other
boxes that this one was holding up
so the other boxes kind of slid down a
little bit and
as i pulled this one um out of the box
the mochi slid
and on these mochi balls there's really
these little decorations
right very pretty and all the it's very
delicate and the decorations got all
[ __ ] up
right and then i'm holding on oh
decorations [ __ ] up
oh well i'm gonna eat one anyway and
then she comes around
and she screams at me you
[ __ ] it up you [ __ ] [ __ ]
those are supposed to be gifts right you
[ __ ] up my
emoji and it was just on and on about
that it was it was at the heels of him
[ __ ] up my sister's uh birthday cake
so um i had ordered uh you and pastry
[ __ ] up
[ __ ] that's another one you know how
like he gets really mad at rudy for
[ __ ] up his uh i brought it delivery
well he [ __ ] up my delivery so for my
sister's birthday i ordered from june i
just didn't didn't
junior is in brooklyn okay
did not know that i don't know what it
was i'm going to show in fact we're
going to put a video up
of how what the cheesecake looked like
when bobby um
handled it so he he also handled the
mochi in a very similar fashion to where
like i was just like you know it's a
very delicate treat and it's so pretty
the way it's
boxed and it just looked like ball on
top of
balls by the time he had clawed into it
so i freaked out and he
i got it was honestly all my fault
genuinely genuinely my fault
and i apologize as soon maybe like five
minutes after screaming i was like oh my
[ __ ] god and then i made what did i
do
i cooked you spam and then eggs and then
rice and then made you fresh juices and
i was like i'm so sorry
i'm just saying in that moment though
there was a moment where i was just like
i did not know that they were for gifts
no one told me anything
you know i'm getting yelled at for no
reason at all
you know the other one the cheesecake is
we can argue we can go to court for that
one
right because i have my own point of
view about do we need it but it's one of
those things that i feel as though like
if you don't
snap your fingers in front of his face
and then say hey
commit this to memory do not drink
this or do do not like for instance like
yesterday
he i told him i've told him this over
the years
don't put bottled drinks inside the
freezer because they will
explode you do that for seven years i've
been telling him this right
he puts this [ __ ] high-pressured
bottle of beet juice inside the freezer
yesterday
because i like the way it tastes when
it's frozen and the whole thing just
explodes into like no idea and then
he goes on he just puts it all in a bowl
with a broken glass and he's like i'm
still gonna have it
and i freaked out and i was like no
you're going to ingest
like glass particles and then you're
going to like freaking injure your
esophagus like you don't do that like
who like i'm not a scientist i'm not a
biologist i don't know these things
right i thought i thought how could beet
juice beat glass
beet class how can beet juice
be glass and i realized beet juice in
ice form can be class now you know for
me i learned through experience so 2
2 2 a.m bobby bobby
don't do it don't do it and then he's
just there with a bowl of beet juice
like this
and i did bite into it and there was a
piece of glass oh yeah and then he
swallowed it
yeah oh and i'm fine he didn't admit to
that until early this morning he was
like you guys i have something to admit
i did have some of that beet juice and
yes there was glass
i did swallow glass okay
so um and i i feel responsible for
for um having yelled at you for the
mochi and i still feel horrible and i'm
so sorry george do not yell
at your spouse rule number five do not
yell
do not yell not over mochi yeah that's
not an important part of life
so when's the day dude wait hold on
that's five yeah
we just let's make it five let's make it
fun let's round it up i can't think of
anything else
now what what's the date for friday